foreign
what exactly are intrusive thoughts
intrusive thoughts are lightning bolts
they are you're walking down the road
and you see somebody in a particular
kind of jeans and you instantly go back
to that girlfriend you had or that
boyfriend you had and then that thing
they said to you like it is Boom or if
heaven forbid you've lost a child or a
loved one
um it's you're just doing something and
you look in that picture of them in the
funeral home pops into your mind or that
feeling you get when something happened
to you years ago and it just it just it
just re-emerges
so that is intrusive thought they just
come
most people think that at the end of the
intrusive thought
the cascading sense of worry and shame
and now my body's trying to protect me
all that I just have to deal with that
and that's not true the moment an
intrusive thought happens boom I'm gonna
take ownership of it so I'm gonna
remember that picture I am choosing I'm
not going to think about my kid at the
funeral home I'm gonna think about my
kid laughing so hard cotton candy and
milk came out her nose at the same time
I'm gonna not intentionally uh by the
time you got dumped and when so-and-so
said this I'm not going to meditate on
that I'm going to meditate on the person
I'm with right now and how much we laugh
together and how much fun we have and
what will happen over time is your
brains will stop it will begin to change
the automatic dial from these moments of
remember watch out to
look how beautiful look how beautiful
look how beautiful
um and quite honestly intrusive thoughts
are just they just are what they are I I
just don't lose a lot of sleep with them
anymore I used to let them run my life
and they just don't get a vote anymore
do you have them
yes I think I do yeah yeah
I think I have interested thoughts of
like more so of I don't trust myself
um I have a huge fear of heights and so
I find myself like if I'm up high
somewhere I'm like I don't trust myself
to like I don't want to hurt myself but
I don't trust myself to not throw me off
this ledge so I just avoid it
I know that seems weird but I should go
see somebody it's like
escalators I hate escalators because I
know there's nothing on the sides of
them and I get on the escalator I'm like
but what if I just like something in me
just is like flips over and I fall out
and I just
and so that's that's a great moment the
moment you think
what if
if you were able to go nope
my body's trying to protect me thank you
I'm good escalators is going to the top
and we're able to cut that sucker off
right there and smile about it not go
but go oh look my brain started to take
care of me again I'm Square I'm good not
a lot of people fall off escalators it
happens they're on Instagram but very
rarely right
um over time your brain will stop trying
to get your attention on escalators
because it knows like oh Jen is fine she
doesn't fall off escalators only
they do right it's awesome very cool